Here's how I figured out the answer.
I started with this node here,
and I noticed that there
were 3 plus 1 units coming in, so
there must be 4 units going out.
Looking at this node down here, I
observe that 10 units are coming in, so
10 units need to come out.
There are two unknown flows going out,
but the capacities are 6 and
4, respectively, for
a total of 10 capacity.
This means that there's no ambiguity.
Both edges must be used
to their full capacity.
That is to say, that they are saturated.
Finally that leaves me with this edge.
We have 4 plus 6 coming in,
and 2 units going out already,
meaning that 8 more units must
go out flowing along this edge.
And I can check my work at the end by
confirming that the amount coming out of
the source,
12 units in this case, is the same
amount that's going into the sink.
Perfect.